you're about to have your baby the show
is about to come out how would you
describe this time for you right now oh
my gosh exciting exciting I don't really
have a lot of other words that could be
the baby brain but ya know it's all
really amazing I'm so excited for people
to see this show it's gonna be great to
be able to watch after I've had my
daughter so it's gonna be really cool
yeah
how was filming the show well pregnant
it was great it was tough at some points
we didn't have a couple super late
nights in really high heels but the
girls couldn't have been better and it
was just so much fun to be a part of the
show with them now this is a
female-driven show is that what drew you
to this project part of it and also just
that I'd never done comedy before and I
was super excited and the character that
I play is just such a free spirit really
loving person and I just thought that
was going to be really fun and different
from a character that I've been used to
be playing now obviously it shows about
to come out what are you most excited
for people to see about the show I want
them to have fun I want them to see that
it's an extremely relatable show and the
relationships that the girls have with
one another is just so special but it's
very funny so you are due soon are you
ready do you have everything but name
picked out at something nurseries not
done I don't know if you're ever really
ready but you know we're as ready as can
be we're almost ready
now with this type of show you said it
was your first time doing comedy how was
that transition for you it was honestly
great I mean the writers were so
incredible so that was really easy and I
feel like our characters were just so
perfectly suited for each of us so it's
really easy to fall into your youtube
series it has been so well-received why
was it so important for you to be so
open with your pregnancy I just wanted
to share my experiences the good the bad
and the ugly and that's what I've been
able to do and I think that it's really
important that we as women are really
honest about this process because it is
a difficult journey so the more honest
that I could be and you know sharing in
my experiences and things that I learn
along the way I mean great the better
for everybody now how would you describe
this show in your own word I would say
it is funny relatable and hurt warming